Billy is a puppy.
He lives in a big house with a blue roof.
He loves to play fetch with Emmy.
Emmy throws the ball.
Billy chases it.
Then, Billy sees Cat.
He drops the ball and chases Cat.
Cat runs down the street, and Billy chases him.
Emmy cries,...
..."Come back, Billy."
Cat runs through a farm, and Billy chases him.
Cat runs into the forest, and Billy chases him.
Cat climbs up a tree.
He cannot see the big house with a blue roof.
"Oh, no, I am lost."
Billy says.
Billy runs down a path.
He sees Fox.
"How can I get home?"
He asks Fox.
"I have never been out of the forest."
Says Fox.
"Ask Cow in the farmer's field."
Fox says.
Billy runs to the farmer's field.
Billy says to Cow,...
"I am lost."
"Do you know the way to my house?"
Billy asks.
"I have never been off the farm."
Says Cow.
"Ask Owl."
Cow says.
Billy goes to Owl in the barn.
"Please wake up, Owl."
Says Billy.
"I need your help."
He says.
"I am lost!"
He cries.
"Do you know a big house with a blue roof?"
Billy asks.
"Yes, I do."
Owl says.
Owl flies, and Billy chases her.
Then, Billy sees Emmy at the big house with a blue roof.
"Thank you, Owl."
Says Billy.